so now we are seeing kids that are
identifying as animals going to school
and they are purring instead of
answering questions and they meow and
the teachers are not allowed to question
it because it's considered a queer
identity so
you have kids are going to school and
they're saying i'm a cat
and the teachers have to
affirm them as a cat
yes so it's not just the
i am a 27 year old transgender woman
i am a wolf therian and a member of the
furry fandom when and how did you
discover this inner wolfeness um
probably around age 10 or 11. i was
watching
an anime about wolves and
see the wolf running across the screen
and i'm somehow just intrinsically like
oh that's me have you spent any time
around biological wolves yes
that sounds dangerous also what context
are you so i was a volunteer with the
preserve and i've also visited many wolf
preserves
are you able to communicate
with the wolves am i gonna have a
conversation with a wolf in the way that
i'm communicating you and i obviously
not am i going to read their body
language respond appropriately to their
behaviors and their nonverbal cues yes
would you would you be able to give us
an example of
this wolf communication um no
i'm not comfortable doing so okay